- On découvre chaque jour que
la destruction de Marioupol
est encore pire que la veille.
On ne s'habitue pas à ces images
de guerre. Mais ceux qui ne
peuvent fuir les bombes
sont forcés de s'habituer
à vivre dans les ruines.
Avant la guerre, la ville
portuaire comptait 400 000
habitants. Selon le maire
de Marioupol, 170 000 personnes
sont maintenant forcées de vivre
comme ça, dans les ruines
de leur demeure. Santututututure
ni eau, sans chauffage
ni électricité.DeDeDeDeDeDes dis
de citoyens enfuis à
leurs risques et périls,
car les Russes tirent
aussi sur des voitures conduites
par des ci
Pavel était dans la voiture
avec son ami qui est enterré
près de son garage.
Marioupol est en train de
devenir un immense cimetière;
les gens enterrent leurs proches
près de chez eux, craignant
de trop s'éloigner. Les convois
d'aide se font toujoursatatatatr
humanitaire doit ouvrir demain.
Cet employé de la Croix-Rouge
explique qu'il vient d'arriver
à Zaporijia, à 230 km
de Marioupol, et qu'il souhaite
venir en aide rapidement
aux habitants de la ville
martyre.
(explosion)
'a'a'a'a'a'a'alarme)
Sur le front politique,
Vladimir Poutine menace
de couper l'envoi de gaz
à l'Europe rererererererefusent
de payer la Russie en roubles.
Si ces paiements ne sont pas
faits, dit-il, nous allons
le considérer comme
un défaut de paiement, et agir
en conséquence. Le chancelier
allemand, son pays dépend
largement du gaz russe, affirme
qu'il ne cédera pas
à ce chantage. Poutine
ne réussit pas depuis
cinq semaines à affaiblir
le front commun des pays
m m m m m m m mais sur le terrn
les bombes russes continuent
leur destruction.
Les soldats ukrainiens sont
fiers d'avoir repris la petite
ville de Trostia s s s s s s s i
l'on trouvait complètement
détruite après 30 jours
de bombardements.
Ici Sophie Langlois,
Radio-Canada, Montréal